Hello World Suraj here.
Big comp is a currency just like
the US dollar or the Japanese,
yet accept bitcoin doesn't
belong to anyone. No one owns it,
no government bank company or person.
It's just open source software
that anyone can download in brows.
It's an invention that no one owns,
but anyone can use kind of like email.
It was created in 2007 by a mysterious
person into Toshi neca mode.
The search was to,
Toshi isn't going on for years,
but no one has ever found him before
and since then the total value of the
bitcoin network has grown from
nothing to over 5 billion US dollars.
Once you joined the bitcoin
network by opening a wallet,
it will generate your way 25 character,
long public and private
key using cryptography.
Hence my big point is called
a cryptocurrency. This
is your bitcoin address.
Think of it kind of like
your bank account number.
You can give your public key to anyone.
It's what the, we use the send money team,
but your private key
is for your eyes only.
Anyone who has a private key
can access all of your funds.
So keep it safely hit every time
someone sends bitcoin to another person.
The bitcoin network is responsible
for processing the transaction.
The bitcoin network has maintained by
a bunch of computers that verify all
transactions to ensure
that they are valid.
This process is called mine and anyone
can set up their computer to become a
miner.
Can get paid for maintaining the network.
All have to do is download the
bitcoin client and start mining.
My new requires a lot of computing power,
so you'll need a really,
really good GPU chip. An AC computer would
work best when anyone gets the client.
Their computer will start downloading
somebody called the blockchain.
The blockchain is a huge list of every
single bitcoin transaction that has ever
happened in the network.
These transactions are bundled
into units called blocks.
These blocks are all chained
together in order of timestamps,
a chain of blocks.
Blockchain get it when
anyone makes a transaction.
Each mine checked to see
if the transaction was ever
made before and it's copy
of the blockchain.
If it was never made before and we'll
recognize it as a valid transaction.
If at least 51% of the network
agrees that a transaction was valid,
it clears and it's
added to the blockchain.
The blockchain is sort on
every miner's computer.
There is no central computer whatsoever.
It's completely decentralized.
That means no one can shut down big,
but what if a bad guy decides he wants
to try to generate fake bitcoins?
Couldn't he just create a bunch of
mining accounts and approve his own
transactions as a new
majority? Well, yeah,
but bitcoin has incredible security system
designed to defend against that type
of attack.
Also known as a civil attack.
There's an extra step that
every miner has to do.
Once it says that a block is valid,
it has to solve a bunch of randomly
generated mathematical problems using its
computing power and
what's the solving them?
Other miners can verify that it
did indeed solve those problems.
This is called the
proof of work algorithm.
Minors have to prove that they've done
a certain amount of computational work
before their vote is valid.
What this means is that more for a bad
guy and spend money twice or dumped spent,
he has to control more computational
power than 51% of the bitcoin network.
The total computational power of the
bitcoin network is currently 13,000 times
greater than the 500 fastest
supercomputers in the
world combined has Kanye
says,
thanks [inaudible] no one person or
entity has that much computing power.
So then then work has never been broken
before and it only gets stronger cause
more miners join like adding
their computing power to
only 21 million bitcoins
can ever be created at the
current rate of creation.
The Alaska Colin would be mined in
the year 21 four so when that happens,
the miners will then be paid with just
transaction fees instead of transaction
fees and generate coins.
This makes bitcoin a deflationary currency
on might be inflationary USDOT do you
pushing her needs?
If there's a hard limit on the amount
of currency that can be created and
inflationary means that more
currency can be created,
but what isn't inherently better
or more natural than the other?
There is no natural state of money.
Its natural state is neither
inflationary nor deflationary.
Money is not a natural thing.
It's a tool we use in our society
to transfer decks amongst ourselves,
turning the dials on the economic models
for money in either direction for both
pros and cons.
Bitcoin can plug into the existing system
or money transfer and make it faster
and more efficient and
more widely available.
There's so many ways to get involved.
Check out the links in the description
from war info and please subscribe for
more technology videos.
Thanks for watching.